سيد مدينه المعالم والعصبه المؤمنه واصحاب
الاخدود يقفز الى عالمنا الحاضر من جديد
من خلال طبعه جديد تظهر في الاسواق
التركيه لكتاب في ظلال القران النسخه
الجديده قدم لها عصام سليمه الاخواني
المعروف المقيم في تركيا ومدير مكتب
القرضاوي سابقا مجرد ظهور الطبعه الجديده
القديمه لظلال القران بمقدمه سليمه الذي
قال عنها انها النسخه الاصليه التي كتبها
قبل تحولاته الفكريه وتنظيراتها التنظيميه
واذا بحمله كبيره على الطبعه والناشر
والمؤلف والاتجاه ووصفت الحمله دور النشر
بذور النشر واعتبرت انه مخطط من مجموعه
ابراهيم منير احد جبهات الاخوان المتصارعه
لتفريغ الجماعه من اليات الصراع التي سنها
وابتكرها قطب في الظلال
واضع اليات التيار الجديد المهادن هو عصام
تليمه ومن وراء الستار الدكتور حلمي
الجزار مسؤول المكتب السياسي السابق في
اخر لقاء جمعه بينهم في منزل يوسف
القرضاوي اثناء مرضه
بالمقابل وصفت جبهه محمود حسين وشركائه
الطبعه بانها طبعه مسروقه ومحرفه ومختلسه
وافته بحرمه شرائها واقتنائها ووصف
والنسخه بالظلال المزيف وشنه حمله على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي على سليمه صاحب
النسخه المنقحه ومن معه اراد عصام تليمه
ومن معه ضلالا بغير المنهج الحركي ظلالا
بدون معالم وفي الوقت نفسه خشيه ليما ان
يقترب من مسائل الحاكميه والعزله الشعوريه
والاستضعاف والجاهليه في تجربه سيد قطب
الفكريه سواء قبل الطبعه الجديده او بعدها
ودون ان يمس رمزيه قطب الجهد في اعاده
التاويل وشرح المقاصد تلك في داخل المدرسه
الاخوانيه ليست جديده لكنها اليوم تاتي
ضمن تحركات لا تدخل في اطار المراجعات او
المناقشات بل هي صراع على المقاعد في مكتب
ارشاد ومجلس الشورى الجماعه والمنقسم ما
بين جبهتين الاولى في اسطنبول والاخرى في
لندن الاخيره مغالبه المنافس من خلال
تاويل جديد لافكار قطب عبر طبعه جديده
للظلال وهي خطوه اعتبرها مراقبون ليست
اكثر من كونها برغماتيه قطبيه فليس هناك
افضل من مدرسه فلسفه الذرائع لاعاده تسويق
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لدى الاخر الغربي
فما حكايه ظلال سيد قطب وهل يعد الترويج
لطبعه جديده من الظلال مقدمه لمرحله
سياسيه جديده تتطلب ادبيات وافكارا جديده
ام انها تراجعات وهل كانت افكار التطرف
لدى سيد طارئه ام حاله اصيله في نفسيته
انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعات
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع والحديث عن تحولات
ومعالم سيد نستضيف معنا من القاهره وزير
الثقافه المصري الاسبق والمؤرخ الاستاذ
حلمي النمنم وله ثلاثه كتب عن من بينها
سيد قطب سيره وتحولات وكتاب بعثه سيد قطب
الوثائق الرسميه حياك الله معنا استاذ
حلمي اهلا وسهلا وطبعا هذا جزء يسير من
مؤلفاتك وغنى المكتبه حقتك يعطيك الف
عافيه شكرا لك حضورك معنا
ومشاركتك يعني معنا لمعلومات الكثيره لديك
من خلال اطلاعك على الوثائق القديمه
المتعلقه بسيد قطب انا سعيد بهذه المشاركه
واشكرك عليه اني ابدا معك حديثنا باني
اسالك هل بالفعل هناك نسخه او طبعه اولى
من كتاب المعالم لسيد قطب وهي مختلفه عن
الطبعات الاخرى وهل حقا ان هذه الطبعه تم
يعني منع تداولها في الاسواق والمكتبات
وعدم طباعتها وترويجها والاكتفاء
بترويج قطب ما بعد السجن
يعني هو في جانبين في هذا الموضوع لا
استطيع ان اقول ان هناك طبعه اولى من
الظلال وطابق الثاني ولكن هناك كتابه اولى
وكتابه اخيره الكتابه الاولى لسيد قطب
كانت بتصدر في اجزاء متناثره عن مكتبه
الحلبي في القاهره
واظن ان بعض نسخ منها ما تزال موجوده في
المكتبه الى يومنا هذا ومعروضه للبيع هي
اجزاء متفرقه وليس تفسير كامل
سيد قطب اعاد بعد ذلك كتابتها بالشكل
الموسع اللي احنا موجودين وبالتالي تصبح
هذه الطابعه الاخيره هي الطبعه المعتمده
من المؤلف التي يمكن الاعتماد عليها اما
الطابعه الاولى فده بتدخل فيما يسمى
بالكتابه الاولى هل فعلا هناك نسخه منقحه
من افكار سيد قطب في ظلال وهي نسخه التي
جاءت بعدها خروجه او خلال فتره وجودها في
السجل طبعا الكتاب خرج اثناء ذلك
وهذه النسخه هي المضافه فيها افكار
الحاكميه والعزله الاجتماعيه والجاهليه او
اما النسخه الاولى او الطبعه الاولى لم
تكن فيها هذه المتضمنه هذه المعاني
خلينا نكون صرحاء
افكار الحاكميه والعزله الاجتماعيه
والاستعلاء وكل افكار سيد قطب في تصور
انها وردت في الظلال الواقع ان هي موجوده
قبل الظلال من يقرا جيدا الكتاب كتاب
العداله الاجتماعيه في الاسلام وده قبل ان
يدخل سيد قطب الى الاخوان فيه كل افكاره
وانا بعتبر ان كل الافكار التي جاءت في
الظلال فيما بعد او في معالم في الطريق او
السلام العالمي والاسلام موجوده حرفيا في
كتابه العداله الاجتماعيه ولو حللنا مضمون
كتاب العداله الاجتماعيه خاصه الجزء
الاخير فيه ده هيوصلنا الى
عقليه ونفسيه وتركيبه الاستاذ سيد قطب ايش
الجزء الاخير فيه الكتاب كتاب العداله
الاجتماعيه في الاسلام من قسمين القسم
الاول اللي هو بحث في العداله الاجتماعيه
والمساله الماليه في الاسلام وده تقريبا
يعني بحث شبه طيب وفي معظمه منقول من
الكتب السابقه
لمفكرين مصريين الجزء الاخير هو طارق
موضوع العداله الاجتماعيه وبدا يكتب في
السلسال حر هذا الاسترسال كان في شقين
شق تم حذفه بدءا من طابعه سنه 64 وهو الشق
الذي كان متعلقا بتشيع واضح لدى سيد قطب
في عبارات كامله وجمل كامله في الطبعه
الاولى والطابعه الثانيه من كتاب في
العداله الاجتماعيه حذفت ابتداء من طابعه
65 من طابعه 64
وده لا نعرف من الذي قام بحذف هذه الجمل
والكلمات والفقرات على سبيل المثال هو
يقول في الطابعه الاولى ان الخلافه
الاسلاميه ابطاءت كثيرا في الذهاب الى علي
بن ابي طالب
وانها اخطات الطريق حين ذهبت الى ابو بكر
ثم عمر ثم عثمان قايل بنفس النص ان
الخلافه اخطات الطريق حين ذهبت الى ابو
بكر والى عمر ثم الى عثمان قال ايضا في
هناك تحامل شديد على بني اميه وقال ان بني
اميه كانوا من المنافقين ولم يعرف الاسلام
طريقا الى قلوبهم يوما واحدا تحدث عن
معاويه بن ابي سفيان وعن ابو سفيان ابن
حرب وقعنا في بني اميه بالكامل فهذه افكار
تشيع واضح في ذلك الكتاب لكن ظلت هذه
الكلمات موجوده الى ان وصار طابع سنه 64
حذف حذف منها هذا الكلام كان هو وقتها في
في السجن من الذي قام بالحزب لا نعرف
وبالشكل عام في قصه الاخوان هم دائما
ينظفون الكتب بين حين واخر وفي عشرات
الكتب في ميراث الاخوان بتحذف منها فصول
طبقا للوقت مثلا مذكرات حسن البنا حذف
منها فصل كامل بيشيط فيه بجلاله الملك
فاروق وكيف استقبله هو والاخوان
فكتاب العداله الاجتماعيه في الاسلام حذف
منه هذا الجزء الجزء الخاص بالشيع الواضح
الجزء الذي لم يحذف وهو المتعلق بافكار
الحاكميه والنظام الاسلامي والعزله وتكفير
الاخرين بل ان هناك فقرات كامله من هذا
الكتاب
انتزعها سيد قطب ووضعت كفصل كامل في كتابه
معالم في الطريق
فتصور ان التطرف سيد قطب وتشدده موجود في
الظلال ووقفا على الظلال تصور غير صحيح هو
تايه قطب متشدد ومتطرف قبل الظلال وقبل
ثوره 52 وقبل ان ينضم رسميا الى جماعه
الاخوان هو الذي ضمه الى جماعه الاخوان
حسن الغضيبي المستشار القضيبي المرشد
الثاني ودي قصه اخرى بسياقات مختلفه في
العلاقه بينهم الاتنين لانه سيد قطب وحسن
الرضيبي كان زميلين في المحفل الماسوني
الاكبر الموجود في القاهره كان عضوين فيه
فبمجرد ان اصبح حسن الغضيبي مرشدا للاخوان
ضم سيد قطب بعد ذلك وكان ضم سيد قطب
للاخوان لكي يضرب به جبهه الشيخ محمد
الغزالي التي كانت منوعه لحسن الهضيب اذا
تسمح لي بدي انوه ان الماسونيه في ذلك
الوقت كانت تجمع يعني نقول ثقافي وسياسي
وفي كان اسلاميين كثير في هذا التجمع يعني
ليس بالشكل الصوره لنفهمها اليوم انا انا
بتكلم انهم ان حسن الهديبي وسيد قطب كان
بينهم علاقه قديمه
وعلاقه خاصه بيهم وده اللي بيفسر سعي
الاخوان الى ضم سيد قطب وضم اليوم سنه 53
تم ضمه رسميه اما قبل ذلك لان هناك هي
النظريه الاخوانيه قائمه على ان سيد قطب
كان ضحيه السجن وتعذيب وتطرف داخل السن
والتعذيب وهذه اكذوبه
لم يعذب داخل السجن ولم يثبت انه عذب
بالعكس كان مدللا بدليل انه اعاد كتابه كل
كتبه داخل السجن
[موسيقى]
هذا الكلام موجود قبل 52 وموجود قبل تجربه
السلك
بالتاكيد تجربه ما كانتش تجربه ايجابيه
ولا تجربه عظيمه لكن في النهايه في
التقييم النهائي مش هي السبب في هذا
التطرف والتشدد قبل السجن مع بدا كتابه في
الظلال من العام 52 الى 54 واذا يعني اذا
كنت مخطئه صحح لي واخرج تقريبا 18 جزء قبل
سجنه وبعد سجنه كمل التفسير
بعد السجن كمل التفسير واعاد كتابه
الاجزاء التي سبق ان طبعك وعشان كده
الطابعه الاولى انا بسميها لا اسميها طبعه
اولى ولا اعتبرها طبعه اولى بتعتبر كتابه
اولى
وعاده في تاريخ الفكر ما بيعتدش كثيرا
بالكتابه الاولى يتم التوقف عندها
لمراجعتها لكي نكتشف مدى تطور الكاتب لكن
هي بتعتبر كتابه اولى اما الكتابه الاخيره
التي اعتمدها المؤلف هي دي اللي بتبقى
طبعا المعتمده وعلى هذا الاساس فان
الطابعه الاخيره من الظلال التي اعتمدها
سيد قطب هي التي ينبغي ان تكون الطبع
المعتمده الطبعه السابقه بنسميها كتابه
اولى او كتابه تجريبيه
وده موجود في تاريخ الفكر الانساني كله
نماذج كثيره لهذا النوع لهذه لمثل هذه
الكتابات
طلعك استاذ حلمي شلف الفرق بين الكتابه
الاولى فيها الاجزاء
الفها قبل السجن والتي اعاد كتابتها
مش طبيعي هل فقط مقتصر على تحريك المعاني
وربطها في الواقع الاجتماعي لا هو في
الكتابه الاولى سيد قطب دخل يعني خلينا
سيد قطب بدا حياته في كتابه الشاعر ولم
ينجح كشاعر لانه كان موجود في وسط قامات
شعريه كبير ثم اتجه الى كتابه الروايه
وكتب روايه اشواق ولم ينجح كرواتي لم يكن
في مستوى نجيب محفوظ ولا محمد سعيد
العريان ولا طه حسين ولا غيره واتجه الى
كتابه النقد ايضا لم يكن في مستوى احمد
امين ولا طه حسين ولا العقاد لان هو كان
بيصنف يمكن ان نصنفه في مستوى كتاب الدرجه
الثانيه او كتاب الدرجه الثالثه في زمنه
في لحظه معينه هو شعر بنوع من الافلاس لم
يعد امامه مجال النقد ليس مفتوحا لا يقدم
فيه اضافه مجال الشعر ليس له فيه اضافه
مجال الروايه لا ينتظر فيه مست كبير في
تلك الفتره وربما الى اليوم بعض الكتاب
حينما تتعطل مواهبهم في جانب معين المجال
الاسهل هو انه يتجه الى كتابه الاسلاميات
فهو اتجه الى كتابه الاسلاميات وكان تعزز
ده لما اصدر كتاب العداله الاجتماعيه
واحتفى به الاخوان واحتفى به بعض كتاب
اليسار باعتباره نوع من الاهتمام بالعداله
الاجتماعيه خاصه انه منذ فتره اثناء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بدا تيار العداله
الاجتماعيه والمطالبه بها يرتفع في مصر
وكان الملك فاروق نفسه احد الذين يتبنون
هذا الاتجاه وظهرت كتابات عديده في عن
العداله الاجتماعيه في الاسلام الملك
فاروق في خطاب العرش تحدث بوضوح في اكتوبر
44 عن ضروره تحقيق العداله الاجتماعيه
كانت تلك اشاره لعدد كبير من الكتاب في
انهم يتجهوا للعداله الاجتماعيه تايد قطب
لم يكن من الاقتصاد ولم يكن يساريا متعمقا
في النظريات الفكريه الخاصه بالعداله
الاجتماعيه زي الاشتراكيه الفابيه او
الماديه الجدليه فاتجه الى العداله
الاجتماعيه في الاسلام باعتبار ان ده طريق
سهل ومفتوح امام مسلم لكي يكتب فيه انا في
تصوري هو الخطوه الثانيه اتجه الى القران
في ظلال القران الكتابه الاولى نحن امام
كاتب هاوي
في الكتابه الثانيه نحن امام كاتب اراد ان
يتخصص في هذا الجانب وبالتالي اعتبر ان دي
قضيته وده مشروع
هو ده الفرق بين الكتابتين السيد في
العداله الاجتماعيه هو نفسه سيد في الظلال
هذا المقصود يعني فيما يخص افكار الحقيقيه
والتشدد هو نفسه لم يتغير ولكن سيد في
العداله
في فكرتين في فكره التشيع الواضحه في
الطبعات الاولى في كتابه العداله
الاجتماعيه اختفت من الطبعات التانيه واظن
ان ده ربما وراها اخوه محمد قرب خاصه حين
اقام في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وانه بيقدموا هذا الفكر
لجموع من المسلمين السنه واذا اللي هيفسر
لنا ويجيب على سؤال لماذا سيد قطب هو
المفكر الوحيد اللي معتمد لدى الثوره
الايرانيه من 79 الى يومنا هذا يعني مرشد
الثوره الايرانيه الى يومنا
علي خاماني ترجم احد كتب سيد قطب
السؤال اللي ما حدش بيحاول يجاوب عنه
لماذا سيد قطب من بين المفكرين هو المعتمد
لدى الثوره الايرانيه منذ
حتى يومنا هذا وبيدافع عنه لانه لديه نبره
تشيع مؤكده وواضحه في كتاب العداله
الاجتماعيه في الاسلام الاخوان حاولوا ان
يخفوا هذا الجانب امام الراي العام في مصر
وفي العالم العربي
بانهم نظفوا الطابعه الاولى من العداله
الاجتماعيه هو في الظلال في الكتابه
الثانيه يبدو ان انتبه لهذا هو خفف من هذا
الاتجاه لم يختفي تماما لكنه خفف منه لم
يعد بناء نفس الحده اضاف اليه في لما عالم
بعد اخر لم نتوقف عنده وهو نظريه
الاستعلاء في كتابه في معالم في الطريق
الاستعلاء فكره للتشاويه وليست فكره
اسلاميه
الاستعلاء فكره نتشاويه الحاديه بامتياز
هو لديه كتاب في معالم في الطريق بعنوان
الاستعلاء ويقول ان المسلم يستعلي في
القوه كما يستعلي في الضعف
يستعلي مع الاقليه كما يستعلي مع الاغلبيه
فكره الاستعلاء فكره للتشاويه الحاديه
بامتياز وهي فكره مضاده لنظريه تاليف
القلوب التي وردت في القران الكريم
وتبناها سيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان في الاسلام في بداياته مع سيدنا رسول
الله دعا الى تاليف القلوب والفه القلوب
سيد قطب وضع في الكتاب في المعالم نظريه
مضاده بالمطلق لنظريه الفت القلوب التي
تحدث عنها القران الكريم واعتمدها سيدنا
رسول الله وهي نظريه الاستعلاء وهذه
النظريه يطبقها الاخوان الى يومنا هذا بما
فيهم الاخوان الذين يسمون انفسهم معتدلون
ابغى اسالك قبل ما ادخل في نقطه اخرى
هل التحولات يعني دائما انا بيرددوا من
الداخل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ان
التحولات الفكريه
بدات مع سيد قطب بعد عودته من الولايات
المتحده يعني اشبه ما تكون بصدمه حضاريه
اصابته هل صحيح هذا لا التحولات لم ترد
لديه بعد عودتهم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كتابه العداله الاجتماعيه كتبه
وسلمه للناس قبل ان يسافر الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وصدرت طبعته الاولى وهو
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكنه كان
قد سلمه للناس وراجع بروفات الطباعه قبل
ان يسافر الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الصدمه التي حدثت له في الولايات المتحده
كانت صدمه شخصيه ليست صدمه حضاريه صدمه
شخصيه فقط لا غير انه راى نماذج من
السلوكيات لم يستوع ولم يهضمها يضاف الى
ذلك انه حين ذهب
الى البعثه كان فوق الاربعين من عمره وكان
بيذهب لزياره مدارس توازي المرحله
الاعداديه في مصر والدول العربيه فهو لم
يستطع ان يتفهم الاجيال الجديده في الغرب
وبالتالي الصدمه التي جرت في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انا تحدثت عنها هي صدمه
نفسيه وشخصيه لاسباب اخرى تتعلق به هو لا
احب ان نتطرق اليها الان
التعلق بتركيبته هو ابغى اسالك بالنسبه
التاثير او التاثر سيد قطب بمن كان في تلك
المرحله خلال كتابته في الظلال من اين جاء
هل كان يعني سطوه ابو الاعلى المودودي في
افكارها ام انه استفاد وطور من افكار ابو
الاعلى المودودي شو طبيعه
الاجتماع ما بين الشخصيتين
جماعه الاخوان كانوا على اتصال بالجماعه
الاسلاميه في
باكستان
وتاثروا كثيرا بابو الاعلى بالاعلى
الموجوده وسيد قطب في بعض التفسيرات كان
في علاقه بين جماعه الاخوان والجماعه
الاسلاميه في باكستان والجماعه تاثرت
بافكار وكتب ابو الاعلى المودودي
وللتاريخ حينما بداوا يصطدموا بجمال عبد
الناصر في مصر ارسل اليهم ابو الاعلى
المودودي رساله انا راجعتها نصحهم بعدم
الاصطدام بجمال عبد الناصر لان عبد الناصر
مسلم فالنظام الحكم في مصر مسلمين وان
تجربتهم في مصر غير تجربه غير تجربته هو
في الهند انهم هم كانوا في الهند كانوا
يتعاملوا مع غير مسلمين واناس معادين
للاسلام فلا ينبغي ان ياخذوا بتجربتهم
لكنهم هم لم يستوعبوا ولم ينصتوا جيدا الى
رساله ابو الاعلى المودودي طيب قطب انتحى
الافكار يعني مش كل افكار ابو الاعلى
المودودي جزء من افكار ابو الاعلى
الموجوده
سيد قطب اضاف لافكار
وعربها واضاف اليها من تجربته الشخصيه
وبلغته العربيه
اسالك علاقه سيد قطب بالضباط الاحرار هل
كان منظرا حركه ضباط الاحرار هذه واحده من
الاكاذيب التي رددها البعض سواء من
الاخوان او من خارج الاخوان علاقه سيد قطب
بدات بعد نجاح ثوره 23 يوليو وخروج الملك
فاروق لما بداوا يعملوا اول تنظيم ليهم
كان بيعملوا اللواء محمد نجيب اللي هو
الاتحاد القومي محمد نجيب قائد الثوره
الضباط اللواء اركان حرب محمد نجيب وكان
شعار الاتحاد القومي الاتحاد والنظام
والعمل
هم استعملوا سيد قطب في هذا التنظيم هو
كان موظفا لديهم وليس منظرا لهم
مش صحيح انه كان منظرا لهم وده في دراسات
ثوره يوليو كانوش محتاجين هؤلاء المنظرين
لانه كان موجود
العقاد العقاد كان مؤيدا لثوره يوليو وله
كتاب مهم في مناسبه ثوره يوليو اللي هو
فلسفه الثوره في الميزان كان طه حسين
موجود كان احمد امين موجود كان محمد فريد
ابو حديد كل هؤلاء كانوا موجودين كان
استاذ القانون الدستوري في جامعه القاهره
الدستور صبر السيد اللي نظر لهم الشرعيه
الثوريه بديلا من الشرعيه الدستوريه لم
يكن سيد قطب منظرا لهم على وجه الاطلاق
ولم تكن علاقته بهم بهذه الدرجه التي يتم
الحديث عنها هو كان موظف صغير لديهم ايش
كان طبيعه الوظيفه يعني ايش هو كان شغال
يعني
في سكرتاريه الاتحاد القومي يعني لا
نستطيع ان نسميه انه حتى كان نقدر نقول
انه امين عام ولا حتى السكرتير عام هو كان
موجود في السكرتاريه في العمل التنظيمي
المنافس في العمل التنظيمي انما انه كان
منذر للضباط الاحرار هذا محض كذب انه هو
اللي كان على علاقه بيهم ويعرفهم قبل 52
هذا لم يثبت على وجه الاطلاق اول تعارف له
بهم بعد 52 وبعد ما مجدهم تمجيد لم لا
يعني قال في محمد نجيب وجمال عبد الناصر
كلاما لا اظن ان نجيب او عبد الناصر نفسه
يجرى ان يقولوا عن نفسه مثل هو في احد
المقالات قال ان بطوله محمد نجيب ورفاقه
تفوق بطوله مطالع النبوات
وضعاهم جنب الانبياء وده كلام لا يحتمل لا
عبد الناصر ولا نجيب ولا عبد اللطيف
البغدادي ولا الزكريا محي الدين ولا اي حد
منهم واتصور انهم كانوا بيسخروا من هذا
الكلام
وربما يكون هذا الثناء المفرط في تلك
الفتره المبكره في حياتهم كان سبب انهم لم
يتعاملوا معه بجديه واخذوه باستخفاف يعني
ايوه عبد الناصر لما كان يتكلم عن العقاد
يقول الاستاذ العقاد لما يتكلم عن طه حسين
يقول عميد ادب العربي الدكتور طه حسين
ويتحدث عنهم باكبار لكن المره الوحيده
اللي اتكلم فيها مع سيد قطب قال له يا اخ
سيد كلمه اخ في اللي يعرف اللهجه المصريه
يعرف ان ديت انت بتقوليها لحد يعني
ما انتوش اصحاب قوي وما انتوش زملاء قوي
لكن حد يعني من باب التلطيف في العلاقات
اللي بينكم ابغى اول شيء اسالك
مرحله ابتعاد عن حركه الضباط الاحرار هل
حضرتك تقول انه هو لم يكن مناظر ولم يكن
له موقع يعني مهم في نفسه في الحركه هذه
بينما البعض بيشوف يدل ان سبب مغادرته
لحركه ضباط الاحرار انه كان عنده يعني
توجيهات معينه نظريات معينه لم يؤخذ بها
تم تهميشها فمن هنا انتقل الى حركه جماعه
الاخوان
وابغى اسالك من هذه النقطه ايضا هل هذا
بعد نرجسي لدى سيد قطب ام ان كان لاغراض
اخرى
اولا بس دعينا نراجع المعلومه نفسها الذي
قال هذا الكلام هو نفسه سيد قطب في
المذكره التي كتبها
ونشرت في احدى مطبوعات مؤسسه الشرق الاوسط
في لندن للطباعه والنشر بعنوان لماذا
اعدموني هو الذي قال هذا الكلام انه تركهم
لخلاف التوجهات لكن بالبحث هو تركهم كان
يتوقع ان يمنحوه منصبا رفيعا هو كان عنده
امنيه انه يبقى وزير المعارف لم يكن في
سلطه عبد الناصر ولا محمد نجيب في وجود
القامات الكبرى في مصر في ذلك الوقت انه
يمنحه سلطه يعينه وزير معارف لماذا لانه
من الناحيه الوظيفيه هو كان موظفا في
الامانه الفنيه في مكتب وزير المعارف
العموميه فما ينفعش ان موظف صغير هو لم
يكن حتى قد وصل الى درجه مدير اللي يعرف
الاداره في مصر ما ينفعش حد
بعد الى درجه مدير يعني موظف في الدرجه
السادسه مثلا انه يرقى فجاه الى درجه وزير
اللي ياتي وزير يكون عنده خلفيه سياسيه
معينه او ادى دور سياسي معين او ادى دور
معين للنظام القائم هو لم يكن لديه هذه
المؤهلات وبالتالي حين شعر انهم لن يعطوه
هذا المنصب
فبدا يبتعد عنهم ده بدايه الابتعاد اما ان
هناك خلاف فكري مش صحيح لماذا لان افكار
الضباط الاحرار منذ 23 يوليو 52 هي هي لم
تتغير
يعني
الغايه اللي تغير بعض الخطوات
الاداريه وبعض الاجراءات لكن اللي يعود
الى بيانات 23 يوليو منذ البيان الاول
الذي سمعناه بصوت المرحوم محمد انور
السادات والقاه يومها السادات والقاه محمد
نجيب اللي يراجع البيانات الاولى سوف يجد
انهم ما كانوش بحاجه الى مناظر فكري وان
افكارهم كانت واضحه اتنين اللي يراجع
منشورات الضباط الاحرار قبل 52 افكارهم
واضحه وبالتالي هو لما راح انضم ليهم ومدح
محمد نجيب وعبد الناصر واللي معاه مكانتش
افكار مستخبيه دول كانوا موجودين في الحكم
وعلى الملا وافكارهم على الملا القضاء على
الاقضاء تحديد الملكيه تحويل مصر الى
جمهوريه الغاء دستور 23 الغاء الاحزاب وكل
هذا يدعو سيد قطب ومجده فيهم بل اكثر من
ذلك سيد قطب طالبهم باعدام كل الكتاب
والباحثين الذين اشهدوا بواسطه محمد علي
وطالب باعدام كل المطربين الذين غ
نوا وسماهم بالاسم لم يستجيبوا اليه نعم
مثل مين كانت فايده كامل ومحمد عبد الوهاب
ومحمد فوزي وكل هؤلاء المطربين اللي احنا
بنسمعهم الى الان
يعني هو ذكرهم جميعا
والمطربه شهرزاد ولم يذكر ام كلثوم لكن هو
ذكر كل المطربين والمطربات ودول قال عليهم
ان دول الذين غنوا للاسره البائده
طالب بان الدوله تعزل محمد شفيق غربال وكل
اساتذه الجامعه واساتذه التاريخ الذين
مجدوا محمد علي واسره محمد علي اشبه بحمله
تطهير يعني استاذ حلمي يا فندم اشبه بما
تقوم به طلبان الان ما تقوم به طالبان
الان في افغانستان طالب به سيد قطب في 52
و 53 مقالاته موجوده في روزا اليوسف
وموجوده في المصري وموجوده في الاخبار الى
يومنا هذا انا قمت بنشرها في احد كتبي لكن
المقالات موجوده وبالتالي ان هو وجد عندهم
ان ما استجابوش فكريان وخلاف فكري هذه
اكذوبه هو ذهب اليهم بمنطق انت هذه اسالك
طيب ليش كتاب العداله الاجتماعيه اللي كان
هو مبكر لم ياخذ هذا انتشار والزخم طالما
ان هذه الافكار نفسها او قريبه من في
الظلال بعكس المعالم في الطريق وفي الظلال
لانه
سيد قطب منذ ان دخل السجن اصبح ملك
الجماعه
اللي بدات
تقدمه الجماعه واملك اخوه محمد قطب هو
اللي بدا يعيد اصدار طباعاته يعني مثلا
محمد قطب في السنوات الاخيره طلع كتابين
كتاب اسمه خصائص التصور الاسلامي وكتاب
اسمه مقومات التصور الاسلامي وقال ان دول
بقلم سيد قطب ونحن ليس لدينا ما يثبت ان
سيد قطب كتبهم ان هذه الكتب نشرت مؤخرا في
التسعينيات من القرن الماضي يعني بعد
اعدام سيد قطب اكثر من 30 سنه وحتى لما
نشروا
ماقدم لناش ورق بخط سيد قطب لكي نتاكد ان
هذه الكتب بقلم سيد قطب يعني نحن لا نعرف
الكتابين دول مين اللي كتبهم هل هو محمد
هل هو حد في الجماعه
لانه اللي يراهم ما يدقق فيهم فيهم قريبين
من من اسلوب سيدو فيها حاجات لا تقترب من
اسلوب ثابت قطب فسيك قطب تحول الى ملك
للجماعه الجماعه هي التي تنظف الكتب هي
التي تنشر كتب بعينها مثلا هم حذفوا من
كتاب السلام السلام العالمي والاسلام
حذفوا فصل كامل وحذفوا بعض فقرات في كتب
سيد قطب هتلاقي كثير من المحذوفات والكتب
كانت بتنظف بين حين واخت وفق هوى الجماعه
والجماعه كانت بتعمل ده مش مع سيد قطب
عملته كمان مع حسن البنا ومع اخرين
كتب سيد قطب هي عباره عن رسائل او مقالات
في الصحف وتم جمعها
بكتاب ووضع عنوان لا من قبل الجماعه ام
انها كانت كتب كامله يخرجها سيد قطب في
بعضها كتب
زي نحو مجتمع اسلامي هو اخرجه ككتاب كتاب
اسمه معركه الاسلام والراسماليه ده كان
مجموعه مقالات في المصري وفي غير المصري
ده كتبها واللي بيقول فيها ان ما الوطن
الا حفنه من تراب من طين عفن بالنص وده
كان بيقولها بيتهكم على الفدائيين
المصريين الذين ذهبوا ليناضلوا ضد
الانجليز سنه الخمسين اللي بيقولوا بعد
كده ان هو اللي كان مناظر الاسطوره لا هو
ما كانش مناظر ده هو انتقد في مقال له في
جريده المصري الفدائيين المصريين وقال ما
الوطن الا حفنه من تراب عفن يعني ابغى
استوضح الزمن التاريخي ليش في هذا الوقت
سيد قطب خرج بهذا
يعني هذا الحديث
سياسي غرض عنده ازمه شخصيه
هو تركيبته الشخصيه كان فيها ازمه هو رجل
كان لديه طموح كبير ولكن كان طموحه لا
يتناسب مع قدراته وامكانياته رقم هو كان
نفسه ان يكون طه حسين او عباس محمود
العقاد وفشل في ان يصبح طه حسين او ان
يصبح عباس العقاد اتنين هو كانت قدراته
الثقافيه والفكريه اقل منهما بكثير جدا
رقم 3 هو الواقع انه لم يثقف نفسه جيدا
لاسباب خارجه عن ارادته هو رجل جاء من
بلدهم من قريه موسى في اسيوط ليدرس في
كليه دار العلوم فلاسباب اقتصاديه كان
يعمل اثناء الدراسه ودي حاجه لا تعيبه
حاجه تشرفه
وبمجرد ما تخرج كان يعمل فلم يكن لديه وقت
لتحصيل ثقافي وتحصيل معريفي كافي يؤهله
لان يصبح كاتبا وهو لم ينتبه الى ذلك لم
ينتبه الى بناء نفسه فكريا ومعرفيا وعلشان
كده لما نرجع لكتبه هتلاقي حضرتك كميه
النقل عن الاخرين بينقل صفحات كامله صفحات
مطوله من كتب وده بالمعنى العلمي الحرفي
يدخل في باب السرقه العلميه حتى لو اشار
لانه انا ممكن اخد جمله جملتين فقره بكتير
اما ان انا اخد صفحات كامله هو مثلا في
كتابه انا اثبت نحو مجتمع اسلامي في صفحات
كامله 14 صفحه بالكامل بالتقديم من مرجع
واحد ده معناه لانه فقير معرفيا وفكريا هو
مع الاسف الشديد لم يتكون معرفيا وثقافيا
حتى بمعايير التراث الاسلامي محمد قط كان
يقول انها شقيقه اعتمد على تفسير ابن كثير
والله حين نقرا
الظلال والقرن بتفسير ابن كثير نشك في هذا
الكلام
انه مثلا حين نقرا تفسيره لصوره يوسف
هو لم يطلع على اي تفسير خالص في القران
ولما اطلع على كتب تاريخ هو تفسير ادبي
بامتياز كلام ادبي او ده اللي احنا بنقدر
نقوله كلام انشائي
لكن لم يطلع على كتب تفاسير في علم
التفسير يعني مثلا كتاب الشهيد الدكتور
محمد حسين الدهبي اللي ترى اختطاف هو
اغتياله رسالته للدكتوراه كانت في جامعه
الازهر انجزها في الاربعينيات هو لم يطلع
عليها
الشيخ محمد الغزالي كان كان هو مراقب ديني
وراقب المحتوى لي في ظلال في ظلال القران
لسيد قطب واعتمدها كما هي فقط حدث تفسير
سوره البروج صحيح هو العلاقه بين الشيخ
محمد الغزالي وسايره قطب كانت ملتبسه ولم
تكن جيده لانه الشيخ محمد الغزالي في احد
كتبه عن المواكب الدعوه انتقد وهاجم سيد
قطب ثم بعد ذلك في طابعه حديثه في
التسعينات حذف هذا الكلام لكن في الطبعات
الاولى موجود لانه كان سيد قط من
المحسوبين على حسن الغضيبي
والشيخ محمد الغزالي لديه في كتبه اتهامات
واضحه
للهضيبي بانه ماسوني والماسونيه عميله
للصهيونيه قايل ده بوضوح في كتبه
فانه مساله انه كان مراقب ديني لكتاب في
الظلال ده ده لم يثبت كتاب الظلال كانت
الجماعه هي اللي متولياه ومتوليه كتب كتب
سيد قطب طب
الفتره ما كان هناك ادراك لخطوره كتابات
سيد قطب يعني بانه
حتى بعدها بسنوات يعني ما كان في اخذ يعني
الكتاب طبع وتم باكثر من يعني طبعات
وتم اصداره باكثر من اصدار في عدد من
الدول يعني انتشر بشكل كبير يعني حتى فتره
جمال عبد الناصر لم تكن هناك رقابه على
الكتب الرقابه على الكتب فرضت بعد 67
قبل كده ما كانش في رقابه على الكتب
وبالتالي
يعني لغايه ممكن ما يكونش بعد 67 ممكن قبل
كده لكن لغايه على الاقل 52 ونهايه
الخمسينات لم تكن هناك رقابه على القطر
وبالتالي كانت الكتب بتنشرها وكتب كتب
كثيره جدا كان بينشر وبتمر وخلاص هي مشكله
سيد قرب كان من الممكن لكتبه ان تمر بدون
اي ضجر بدون اي شيء ان هناك تنظيم تبناها
هي المشكله ليست في كتب سيد ولكن في
التنظيم الذي تبناه اما كتب سيد قطب
وافكاره من السهل جدا ضحضها ونقدها
تحولت النظريه لدى وجود تنظيم
وعلشان كده كتاب معالم في الطريق لما صدر
سنه 62 سمح بطبعته حين تكررت طباعاته
والاجهزه الامنيه قلقت منه
ودفعوا بالنسخه الى جمال عبد الناصر لما
قال عبد الناصر كتب قال هذا الكتاب خلفه
وتنظيم وثبت فعلا لان ده دي كتب تنظيميه
فالقضيه في سيد قطب ليست في افكار ولا في
كتبه اكم في مصر ناس كتاب وغير كتاب قدموا
افكار متشدده جدا اللي يرجع للجبارتي مثلا
هيلاقي عنده افكار متشدده جدا في كتابه
عجائب لكن هذه الافكار ما عملتش ازمه
كبيره لان ما فيش تنظيم تبناها وكانت سوق
الافكار مفتوحه ما احنا هنلاقي مثلا
استطيع ان انا اعدد لك عشرات الاسماء
قالوا افكار متشدده سواء في الجانب الديني
او في الجانب العلم ومع ذلك ما احدثتش ضجه
لان في النهايه مجرد كتاب او بتصبح الكتاب
مشكله حين يتبناه تنظيم وياخذ هذه الافكار
ويحولها الى يحاول ان يفرضها على الناس
فرضا يعني انا اتفق معك استاذه حلمي في
الموضوع لان كثير من القيادات في ما يسمى
بالصحوه لهم مؤلفات ومنفسته يعني حتى في
الجامعات الجهاديه مثل جماعات التكفير
والهجره عبد السلام فرج وغيرهم كثير كل
واحد كان يطلع بمنافسته خاص له لكن في
ظلال القران له بعد اكثر زخم الى اليوم لا
زالت القصه ظلال دائما ما تخرج من جديد
حتى ان بعد هذا
المشاده ما بين الجناحين في جماعه الاخوان
في معرض الكتاب في القاهره مؤخرا يقول لك
انه كان في اقبال كبير على كتب سيد قطب
يعني وكان تنافس يعني على
حظوه معرض القاهره الدولي كتاب الاخير انا
شفتها الصراحه في منشورات لهم على
الفيسبوك كانوا يعني شخصيات انا ذهبت الى
المعرض عده مرات ولفيته جيدا ما كانش
موجود كتب سيد قطب ما كانش موجود ما كانتش
موجوده في معرض الكتاب لكن هم يعني
الجماعه بتشيع ده والجماعه بتعمل قنابل
دخان لتوث انها ما تزال موجوده وما تزال
مرغوبه ومطلوبه لكن كتب سيد قطب لم تكن
موجوده في معرض القاهره الدولي للكتاب في
دورته الاخيره طب استاذ ابي لو تحكي لي
بايجاز كيف بدا
العلاقه الرسميه ما بين سيد قطب وجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين
وايضا هل حقا هناك تيار بناوي نسبه لحسن
البنا وتيار قطبي يعني الحقيقه ده كلام هم
بيحاولوا يقولوه في مواجهه من يعترضون على
يعني
جماعه يتبنون افكار سيد قطب اذا وجدوا
المجتمع بيضج من افكار سيد قطب واجهزه
الدوله بتضجه من افكار سيد قطب فيقسموا ان
لا علاقه لهم بسيد قطب وانه لا يعبر عنهم
وانهم يتبنون افكار حسن البنا وانهم اتباع
حسن البنا يعني انا هقول لحضرتك واقعه في
سنه 12
في سنه 11 و12
في سنه 11 انا اصدرت كتابي عن حسن البنا
حسن البنا الذي لا يعرفه احد وبدات اكتب
عنه لما جم في سنه 12 الاخوان حكموا مصر
2012 2012 في 30 يونيو 2012 حين تولى
الحكم وانا كنت وقتها اعمل رئيس لمجلس
اداره مؤسسه دار الهلال جاءتني رساله
واضحه من احد قيادات الجماعه بالنص
قل في سيد قطب ما تشاء لا شان لنا به ولكن
احذر ان تقترب من حسن البنا
فاعدت طباع الكتاب حسن البنا رد عليهم ثم
تقدمت باستقالتي من مؤسسه دار الهلال فهما
بيقولوها لما يلاقوا المجتمع بيضج من
وقتها كنت عملت دراسه في المصور اسمها
ميدان التحرير يرصد سيد قطب وجبت الشعرات
التي كانت في ميدان التحرير وان كلها
شعارات مضاده لافكار سيد قطب فهما حينما
يحرجون امام افكار سيد قطب يقولوا نحن
التيار البناوي بالمناسبه
التكفير في رسائل حسن البنا اشد من
التكفير لدى سيد قطب سيد قطب واضح
يعني مثلا في احدى رسائل حسن البنا يخاطب
المواطن المصري لا تتعامل مع الصيدلي
المسيحي لا تتعامل مع البقال المسيحي
اذا في خلافات بين الاخوه لا تذهبون الى
البوليس المصري ولا الى القضاء المصري
تذهبون الى الجماعه لتحل لكم مشاكلكم يعني
هو بيقود الدوله من اساسها فمش صحيح ان في
طيار بناوي معتدل وتيار متشد الطيار سيد
قطب سيد قطب متشدد لكن متشدد صراحه
وعلانيه اما حسن البنا فانا في تصوري هو
اخطر بمراحل من سيد قطب
هل بتشوف مثلا ما بين هل نقدر نصرف مثلا
ان ما بين التيار البناوي والتيار القطبي
والتيار البناوي نقول
التيار القطبي مادي يعني في مرحله
رفع السلاح او التغلب اما التيار البناوي
يكون
المرحله السياسيه يعني كانه
على حسب ما يعني ما تضع السياسه رحالها
للجماعه
ما تنسيش حضرتك
انه ثابت من الوثائق ان المستشار احمد
الخازندار اغتيل بتوجيه مباشر من حسن
البنا للجماعه
محمود الصباغ اثبت في مذكراته وكذلك
الشيخ احمد حسن الباقوري ان الزعيم احمد
ماهر اغتيل من قبل الجماعه
وبالتكليف مباشر من حسن البنا
ده احنا لا ينبغي ان ننسى ذلك
محمود فهمي النقراشي اوتيل في وجود البنا
ومن تنظيم البنا
فمساله ان رفع السلاح قاصر على سيد قطب
سيد قطب هو قالها صراحه لكن الذي شكل
التنظيم الارهابي والتنظيم الخاص الذي نفذ
الاغتيالات هو حسن البنا لكن هناك كتاب
دعاء لقضاه والتبرا من
تنظيم سيد قطب في داخل الجماعه
فبدي اعرف ايش رايك في هذا الموضوع وايضا
نقدت الميساني
للتيار القطبي محاوله الخروج من اثره
وكذلك ابغى اذا تسمح لي وباجاز
هل بايعه بشكل رسمي سيد قطب الهضيبي وكيف
كانت طريقه هذه الالتقاء يعني في لحظه
المبايعه لا هم انه بايعه هو بايع
بايعه متى وكيف نحن لا نعرف بيعه السريه
بينهم الاثنين لكن البيع انه حينما كان
جمال عبد الناصر وزيرا للداخليه فقدم اليه
طلب للموافقه للترخيص لمجله الاخوان
وافق ووقع نبهه احد من العاملين في المكتب
انه رئيس التحرير الذي اختير هو سيد قطب
فاستدعاه عبد الناصر لانه كان لسه موجود
في الاتحاد القومي بتاعهم
فساله يا اخ سيد بالنص يا اخ سيد هل انت
من الاخوان قال له لم اكن وقد اصبحت
تركهم وسافر الى سوريا والاردن في مهمه
اخوانيه مكلفا من المرشد حسن الهضيبي مثل
هذه المهمه يذهب الى الاردن ليقابل اخوان
الاردن ويذهب الى سوريا ليقابل سوريا في
مهام رسميه لا يمكن ان بتكليف مباشر من
المرشد لا يمكن الا ان تكون
العضو عامل وليس متعاطف ولا محب رقم اتنين
مساله دعاء لا قضاه وانتقادات
المرشد الثالث عمره تلمساني لافكار
سيد قطب التكفيريه هذه بناخذها في محمل
صراعات الاجنحه داخل الجماعه
وليست من يقترب من الدوله الوطنيه والدوله
المدنيه او لا يقترب هم جميعا ضد الدوله
الوطنيه وهم جميعا ضد الدوله المدنيه بلا
استثناء لكن دي صراعات الاجنحه الدائره
بينهم زي الصراع اللي موجود الان بين
جماعه لندن وجماعه اسطنبول او جناح محمود
حسين وجناح ابراهيم منير هو صراع بينهم
على ايه الصراع على النفوس وعلى المال
اختم بهذا السؤال من ساهم في اسطره سيد
قطب هل هي نشاط جماعه الاخوان وتفرعاتها
يعني من التيار السروري لاحقا ومختلف
مشتقات الحركات الاسلام السياسي ام ان
هناك اسباب اخرى لاسطرتها سجنه اعدام
سيد قطب وراءها الجماعه
وراها الجماعه الجماعه جرت به واخفت وجوهه
المختلفه واظهرت الوجه الذي يناسبها
اغفلت وجه التشيع لديه غده الطرف عن وجه
الالحاد لديه في نظريه الاستعلاء واظهرت
الجانب الذي
يناسبها فاسترت هو اما انه اعدم في
النهايه هو اعدم بعد محاكمه وتنظيم طيب
هندي نموذج اخر ما شهدي عطيه الشافعي قتل
داخل السجن في التعذيب يعني لم يحاكم ولم
يعدم قتل في التعذيب ومع ذلك لم يتحول الى
اسطوره وعذب وقتل مظلوما لم يتحول الى
اسطوره لانه لم يكن وراءه تنظيم يجعل منه
اسطوره في الواقع الشافعي هو اللي يمكن ان
يقال عنه انه شهيد فعل
كيف استقبل استاذ حلمي التيار اليساري
لسيد قطب لما
اصدر في
العداله الاجتماعيه بعض اليساريين اعتبروا
الكتاب يقترب منه انه بيتبنى فكره العداله
الاجتماعيه بعض اليساريين اعتبروه قريب
منهم وانه ممكن انه يبقى واحد منهم مكان
ليبرالي سيد قطب في هذه المرحله سيد
البراري سيد قرب لم يكن ليبراليا في اي
يوم من حياته
في كتابه في العداله الاجتماعيه في
الاسلام في بعض التيارات اليساريه راوا
انه ممكن يكون قريب منهم وده اللي جعل
ناقد كبير زي الدكتور عز الدين اسماعيل
رحمه الله انه عمل دراسه مهمه جدا نشرت في
مجله الثقافه في نقد وتثميد كتاب
العداله الاجتماعيه
لانه ولما تناقشت معه هو كان استاذي في
الجامعه كان عميد الكليه وانا طالب قال لي
انه وقتها لقى بعض اليساريين بيقولوا على
سيد قطب ده ممكن يكون فولكير المصري وهو
شعر ان له بيتم تخليها لو نورتنا في هذا
الحديث وكان ودي صراحه انه يعني
نناقش محاور اخرى كثيره في
اطار حياه سيد قطب وتحولاته الفكريه
ومراحله الفكريه واتجاهاتها واسمح لي اختم
هنا الله يسلمك استاذ حلمي شكرا الف شكر
رفعت كلماته سيد قطب على حيطان مدن الرقه
السوريه والموصل في العراق حيث كانت خلافه
داعش واطربت قبل ذلك زعيم القاعده اسامه
بن لادن وايمن الظواهري في جبال تورابورا
والذباح ابو مصعب الزرقاوي ومعلمه المقدسي
لكن اليوم يتطلب من معسكر الاخوان مرحله
جديده وطبعه جديده من الظلال منزوعه الدسم
الى حين هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]